sex and the summit how prostitution
blooms during World economic foreign
sex work gets a boost like every year if
you can go to the numbers because we
like data here yeah uh 20-minute report
to six worker agents in our located 100
miles hundreds or something uh okay
there it is to book one of the sex
workers for four hours her escort
company charges around 1630 while one
night can cost up to 27.70 US dollars
does anybody look down at the I'm not
totally an advocate for this by the way
the go-getters these girls are traveling
all across the world God bless them
getting out there being entrepreneurs
saying I gotta go fight you know follow
the money FTM oh these girls are going
after the millionaires when I go after
like the Tom Dick and Harry's the strip
clubs of the world there's no hate
anyway there's a fun fact the oldest
profession in the world as well do you
know prostitution yeah like the oldest
job using your hands we're going through
prostitutes get that money girl get that
back but good for listen I'm good for
them is there a possible way to find out
I'm telling you you're such small
thinkers why prostitutes are small
thinkers why what would you do first of
all if you're if you're a prostitute
asking for that kind of money what does
that mean the only reason somebody would
pay 27.70 for a night is you have to be
hot ain't nobody paying 27.70 so if you
are part of the small percentage of
women in the world that are hot 20 grand
you're only taking 27 7 what a small
thinker you are go to Palm Beach go to
at a restaurant called Meat Market yeah
and finally stay at the bar I guarantee
you show up for 90 days
you will lock up a billionaire okay 100
that's the small thing motivational
quote a lot of things do I think if
they're smart but sometimes they've just
got a disaster for a personality I would
imagine that's harder easier said than
done because billionaires a lot of times
are smart too and they're like you know
I'm not here for your person but the
billionaires did what happens to them is
when the blood circulates in different
aspects of their body yeah they're not
that smart you know so sometimes you
know history has proven that sometimes
we don't make the best decisions
are you thinking with yeah essentially
obviously none of us here have ever we
are very one very focused groups
that's right well but maybe the
prostitutes need like an entrepreneur
like imagine Pat being that like the
leader of them like how their business
would [__] Skyward oh my God can you
be doing no what would happen to be in
jail the way yeah
I mean I'll take that back yeah worth it
no I mean you would be the perfect I
would it would be professional and it
would it would be a billion dollars
ladies we gotta think big but I think
it's too small I'm actually being very
very serious what percentage let's let's
play a game here okay what percentage of
men would you say are eight or higher in
looks eight or higher in the world in
this room
you get lost in my eyes yeah I'm talking
symmetry or are you talking about
shoulders okay okay let me show you what
I'm worth great shape thank you maybe a
twirl next time yeah yeah different
podcast different podcast at least one
out of the four let's say what I'm used
to doing the ones yeah thirty percent
twenty percent Thirty
percents what do you what types what are
you talking about good looking guys okay
so first of all Define good looking guys
look at all the guys in this room we're
all good looking okay so what is Adam
what does Adam and looks let's not go
here I have I have been I have been dry
humping him with my eyes since I got in
this room I'm giving Adam a solid a
solid eight okay
by the way by the way I'm being so
serious with you tell me what percentage
20 I think it's less it's probably less
but I'd say this I'd say 20 if you look
at like there are men that are athletic
enough I'm going to give it a 20 it
depends on where but guys who work out
in this in this let's just take let's
take Southern Florida
where you can or California I mean it
depends on where you're at I think it is
20 I was in I was in Fort Wayne Indiana
yeah yeah and by the way you know what I
would you know I I have I have a major
pushback let me let me tell you okay but
but here's how I process it what is an
eight let's define in it is it just fit
like total past you said looks though
that's why I was going to be bluish
Better Way what percentage of the men
actually get laid can date where where
where they can go on a dating app and
women swipe whatever less than 20 I
think less than 20. I'm gonna say it's
20. yes less than twenty twenty or less
yeah higher than 15. 80 20. about 20
because otherwise they wouldn't be
making this kind of money and it
wouldn't be said because women are not
as ruthless and physical as men in terms
of when they're looking for a mate
sometimes the guy can be if he's got if
he's wealthy if he's driven ambitious
great personality those things get you
ahead man though that's a different
thing you know like there are a lot of
guys that aren't uh that might be a six
five on paper but they're killing it
because they've they've just got it
they're just they're a boss so that's a
better idea I would say it's still 20
where I'm going with this where I'm
going with this is so it looks alone is
not going to get you uh uh uh you know
what you want right so you can still
have the looks and screw up and not use
the looks that was gifted to you because
you didn't do anything about the looks
that's purely genetics right yeah okay
then comes what then comes you know
market value what you make your you know
purchasing power whatever you want to
call that you're making good money
you're making good earnings then it's
your body you take care of your health
there's a lot of guys that have good
looking faces but they don't take care
of their health their body so they're
not you know they're you know not in
good shape and then there's
communication persuasion you know
telling jokes being witty being
complimentary being curious that's a
complete different skill set that you
have but when it comes down to you know
women if you have the percentage okay
put the percentage for women as well
eight or higher what do you think it is
oh that's way you're going to say same
percentage no way I think it's more I
think women now have technology it's
like and they've always assessment yeah
I mean if I'm if I don't if I'm not a
good looking guy I can wear a shiny
shirt bro and have a nice watch there's
an industry because there's a medical
industry and a fashion industry
dedicated to creating Illusions so that
you look like you cut light well I don't
have those options man right you know
what I'm saying I mean I do obviously
but you know but you know what I'm
saying yeah so so but but I would say
honestly women think about it like the
like when when you're at a bar but
that's not a good metric of prostate
prostitution is a yeah cause you're
about to make a point we want to make a
point off your of your number no no
because the whole concept of
prostitution is you know when we were in
the Army there was this strip club down
the from Fort Campbell Kentucky we had
this one guy at the at the the unit
every month he was broke so finally one
of the roommates were like dude this
guy's an E4 he's making 1500 bucks a
month okay why is he broke at the end of
the month he had this one stripper he
would go to and he was kind of she she
promised him she loved him and she
wanted to marry him never kissed never
had nothing wow but you have to realize
he was a four though yeah yeah but she
was a eight a nine that convinced him
and he Pro she probably had 10 of them
so she's making 10 a month at
Clarksville every month he would give
her a thousand dollars okay so if you're
making 10 grand a month in Clarksville
dude you're rolling I don't know if
you've been to Clarksville there's
nothing you're the mayor yeah yeah
you're the mayor give her a grandma a
grand a month and his income was 1500
we're like how are you this bro he never
got laid never got laid never once got
two years never got late so he got he by
the way not just late nothing he didn't
get laid but he got [__] yeah
you're right basically he did There's is
a technical term for that type of guy
he's called a simp
or a mark that's for sure so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]